في وقفه مع الحدث مشاهدينا الكرام التي
نخصصها لهذا الملف نتحدث اذا عن هذا
الموضوع مع زميلا وسيم الاحمر اهلا بك
وسيم
باسباب هذه الازمه في العلاقات بين باريس
و الرباط
[موسيقى]
في العلاقات بين المغرب وفرنسا في الاشهر
الاخيره هناك اسباب كثيره يعني همم نعود
الى التذكير مثلا مع عرف بقضيه
المغرب بمحاوله تجسس على شخصيات فرنسيه
لكن هذا سبب مشكله في العلاقات اتت قضيه
التاشيرات عندما قررت فرنسا في سبتمبر
الماضي خفض عدد التاشيرات والفيز الممنوحه
للدول من الدول المغاربيه المغرب وتونس
الجزائر لكن المغرب همم معني الان
بتخفيضها بنحو 50%
احتجاجا على ما قالت باريس انذاك بانه رفض
لهذه الدول التعاون لمنح همم اذن عبور
للمرحلين للمهاجرين في فرنسا وراين مثلا
تجليا لهذه القضيه مع عدم قبول المغرب همم
الامام المرحل من فرنسا في الاشهر
والاسابيع الماضيه اضافه الى كل هذا هناك
القضيه الاساسيه التي تنظر الرباط الى
علاقاتها مع العالم من منظرها كما قال
العاهل المغرب في خطاب من خطاباته هي قضيه
الصحراء الغربيه اذ منذ عام 2020 بشكل خاص
وبعد اعترافه الولايات المتحده ضمن مثلا
التطبيعه مع اسرائيل بيه سياده المغرب على
الصحراء تحث الرباط الدول
الاوروبيه دول بشكل خاص على اتخاذ موقف
واضح من هذا الشان وتعتبر ان موقف باريس
غير واضح ملتبس وهذا ما اشار اليه حتى
الملك كان هناك بعض الدول الاوروبيه لديها
موقف غير واضح في قضيه الصحراء هذا الامر
من اسباب ايضا الفتور في العلاقات واتد
زياره همم الرئيس الفرنسي الى الجزائر
ودفئ العلاقات انصح التعبير مع الجزائر
وصور مثل الاجتماع الفرنسي وقاده عسكريين
في الجزائر وخروج هذه الصور مغربيه اثار
نوع من الريبه يمكن القول تم التعبير عنه
عبر همم في وسائل عده كل هذه الاسباب
مجتمعه واسباب اخرى الحلقه قاده الى فتور
في العلاقات بين التجليات لها عدم وجود
سفراء للبلدين مثلا خلال فتره همم سفير
الفرنسي في رمضان يتم التجديد تم تعيين
السفير قبل ايام ليستقبل
الوزيره الفرنسيه الان هو كريستوف همم
سيفيك الفرنسي الجديد في الجزائر همم في
المغرب
والعلاقات لم تشهد
الاطار الطبيعي لها حتى تعبير الاشهر
الماضيه الان هذه الزياره يعول عليها
باعاده كما ذكرت الدفع
الامور
الرباط ااه ربما
قد لا تنهر ربما الفطور في العلاقات
لعوده هذا الضيف كما تتفضل
الى طبيعته الى مجراه سبق هذه الزياره
بدات خطوات اولا انا يعني عدم التواصل صح
التعبير همم بين البلدين كان هناك اتصال
هاتفي بين الفرنسي المغربي
همم وزراء داخليه وعلى مستوى الدبلوماسيين
للاعداد لزياره دوله اجلت او لم بيتم
جدولاتها خلال همم فتره طويله للرئيس
فرنسي يفترض ان تتم في يناير المقبل الان
ايضا همم يعني اذا لاحظنا التصريحات
الفرنسيه بشكل خاص مواكبه لهذه الزياره
سواء الناطق باسم خارجيه او حتى وزيره
الخارجيه خلال الحديث في في المغرب تركيز
على الجوانب الايجابيه في العلاقات على
علاقات مميزه على التبادل وجود البشري
بشكل خاص وجود الطلاب تعطي ارقام 46,000
طالبا مثلا مغربيه في فرنسا
وفي الوقت نفسه الحديث عن تطورات ايجابيه
في مساله تاشيرات دون الاعلان صراحه عن
رفع الحظر او القيود على منح هذه
التاشيرات وبالتالي هنا السؤال هل فعلا
هذه القضيه ستطوى بشكل نهائي ستحل ام انها
فقط هي اعاده تحريك الحوار بشان الشيرات
فيما يتعلق مساله الصحراء الغربيه وهدم
مهم كان لافتا اليوم في تصريحات مقابله
صحفيه في في المغرب لوزيره خارجيه خلال
هذه زياره لصحيفه همم لوماتنا راها الان
على الشاشه تقول ان موقف باريس ليس غامضا
وليس ملتبسا كما يصور في المغرب انما هي
منذ 15 عاما تدعم خطه الحكم الذاتي التي
طرحتها الرباط وان هدفعت عنها في كل
المحافل الدوليه وبان الموقف واضح وانه
يقف الى جانب المغرب في هذا الاطار هي همم
وتقول بان المغرب يمكن ان يعتمد على فرنسا
على دعم فرنسا في المحافي في هذا الايطار
وظهوره العوده الى المفاوضات الدبلوماسيه
بمعنى انها لم تغير موقف باريس بهذا الشان
بقدر ما هي توضحه تحدده يعني لم تقول ان
فريسه تعترف في سياده المغرب على الصحراء
او همم تغير من موقف معلن بقدر ما هو
التوضيح وموقف الدفاعي السؤال يبقى ان كان
هذا سيكفي
مغربياطي هذه الصفحه ايضا شكرا جزيلا
الاحمر على هذه